All right, in this section, we're gonna be talking
about the LED volume, its hardware, and its processing.
All right, here at the latte stage in Culver City,
the wall that we utilize implements
Black Pearl II panels from Rho,
and these panels are 176 pixels by 176 pixels,
and they have a pixel pitch of 2.8 millimeters.
We have two walls.
We have our main wall and a side right-angled wall here.
The main wall is 10 panels across by five panels down,
which give us a resolution of 1,076 pixels by 880 pixels,
while the right-angled wall is a five-by-five panel wall.
It's 880 pixels by 880 pixels.
We also have a wild wall,
which is an 85-inch 4K Sony television.
The resolution for it is 3,840 by 2,160,
but we have our television rotated vertically,
so it would be 2,160 by 3,840.
This particular configuration
is a great small stage configuration.
It works well for simple purposes,
and the panel configuration
with a 2.8-millimeter pixel pitch
is pretty good for a small environment,
though an even tighter pixel pitch
would probably be a little bit better.
All right, for this particular stage,
I'm showing a simple wired diagram
of how the signal flow is.
You have house time code and house genlock,
which are feeding specific signals to the mocap network,
the camera that's filming the LED wall,
any type of recording or capture material,
like the Q-Take at the LA R&D stage,
or our simple little Kona field recorder
and Kona capture card
in our facility here in our control machine.
Time code and genlock signals
are also sent to each control computer
and also to each render computer.
The render computers are equipped with the A6000 GPUs.
They need to be genlocked
to make sure that they are drawing pixels
in synchronization to the actual wall.
The video signals from the render computer,
along with the time code and genlock
that's being transmitted,
will leave those computers
and be routed over to the LED processors.
And the LED processors in this particular facility,
the Latte Stage,
this is being driven by the Brompton Tesra SX40.
So it receives a video signal in via HDMI
in this particular case,
and it also receives time code in and genlock in.
The Tesra will then take that video signal
and it'll convert it
to a 10 gigabit fiber video over IP signal
and send it to the distribution units.
So they're the Brompton distribution units.
They'll take that 10 gigabits video over IP signal
and break it into smaller one gigabit over video IP signals
and route that signal and daisy chain it
to each individual panel.
Now, the way that that is configured
is handled through the Tesra software.
So if we look at that software,
Brompton will give you the way
to specifically configure how the panels
will draw and handle that signal.
So if you look on the slide here,
you see that we have A1, A2, A3, 4, 5, 6, 7, and 8.
These each have the specific signal flow
as to which panels are hooked up
and handled by the processor.
And if we look with my camera here,
you can see that we have those individual regions
on the screen.
One will handle between panels E01 through A01,
where two will handle E02 all the way up and over
and down, and then you have 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, and 8.
And each one of these are gonna be controlling
the way the video signal is handled
and processed by the wall.
Now for cameras within side of this facility,
there's an array of different choices.
We normally like to kind of categorize our high end camera
versus our mid range camera and a low end camera.
So for the NAND stage and the LA R&D stage,
we're running with an Arri Alexa Mini LF camera.
This is a large format sensor, full frame.
It has no crop factor, essentially 0.98 or 1X crop factor.
It is a rolling shutter sensor
and the body price comes clocking in at around $60,000.
So it is a fairly high end camera.
Once you finally get it all decked out with lenses
and video assist and your tripod
and any other additional accessories you might want,
like a follow focus and so forth,
this particular high end camera can hit six figures
at times.
The mid range that we're using here at the Latte stage,
this is a Blackmagic Ursa Mini camera, 4.6K generation II.
It's a super 35 millimeter sensor, a little bit smaller,
but it does have a crop factor of 1.5X
and it also is a rolling shutter based camera.
Finally, for more independent or low entry level
or broadcast solution cameras that you might wanna use
for indie production or for broadcast production,
we've got like the Panasonic BGH1,
which I have sitting here on my desk.
This is a micro four thirds sensor.
It has a crop factor of 2X
and a body price of about two grand.
This system fully decked out right around $5,000
with your individual video monitor,
lenses, the camera body,
and any other extras that you might want.
Now, when we talk about cameras,
there's something that you should really be aware of.
There are basically two output signals
that you can have from a camera,
whether it's SDI or HDMI.
There is a general preference
that you'll find at most studios.
Most studios will rather work with SDI,
serial digital interface, versus HDMI,
which is high definition multimedia interface.
Now, SDI has a big advantage
in the sense that it can run longer cable lengths
than HDMI.
After a certain point,
HDMIs might require repeaters
in order to potentially run a longer cable.
And anytime that you're adding in additional repeaters
or signal enhancers,
there's a chance that you might introduce some latency.
But SDI comes in a number of different flavors as well.
There's HD SDI, which is a 720p signal
running at 1.48 gigabits per second
worth of data and information,
all the way up to 12G SDI,
which will handle a 2160p 60 frames per second signal.
And it's running at 12 gigabits per second
worth of data and information.
So the thing to remember about this,
the faster your SDI speed gets, like the 12G SDI,
the more sensitive these particular cables
and circuitry can be to voltage issues and problems.
So you're always wanting to remember
to make sure that you're dealing
with grounded components and equipment,
that your power is hooked up
before you start hooking up your BNC cables.
If you don't have a grounded source
and you plug in an SDI cable,
there's a chance that you might short out
the SDI circuitry and completely destroy your camera.
And that's not something that you wanna do.
Talking about timecode.
Timecode, in essence, it's a signal
and a way to divide the measurement of time across frames.
So timecode generators will synchronize the first frame
across all common devices that are hooked up
to a timecode generator.
Normally you'll have one in your machine room
along with a genlock generator as well.
There are two flavors of timecode.
You have linear timecode or LTC,
which is basically a signal that will be written
onto the audio track.
Whereas there is a vertical interval timecode
or VITC timecode that can actually be written
into the video track.
So the big difference between the two,
VITC timecode will allow you to scrub your playback
or slow down or speed up your playback
and it'll maintain timecode effectively.
Whereas linear timecode doesn't have that option.
Like I said, it's being written onto your audio track
and you cannot deploy any kind of slowing down
or speeding up of playback speed, recording speed,
or scrubbing that at all.
So there is a limitation with LTC.
The big advantage of LTC is it's pretty much more common.
And there's a number of ways that you can use LTC
and take that recorded material and synchronize it
in your software.
Like whether you're using some form
of nonlinear editing tools to put this all together.
There is a process that we commonly call jamming timecode.
Now on some cameras, the Blackmagic Ursa in particular,
it only has one BNC port to actually handle
either timecode or genlock.
And I'm gonna pick up my camera here.
I'm gonna show you what that looks like
on the Blackmagic.
So if we look at the Blackmagic camera,
you're gonna see that there are three ports here.
I'm gonna move this out of the way so you can see.
You can see that we have an SDI out,
we have an SDI in,
and we have reference in and timecode in.
It's this bottom port down here
that handles both timecode and genlock
for this particular camera.
There is one more SDI port up here in the front,
but this basically will lead to your field monitor
that we have attached here.
This is the Atomos Shogun.
But getting back to jamming timecode,
the nice thing about most professional cameras
is that they have their own timecode clock inside of it.
And that clock is very accurate.
And when you jam timecode,
you're basically taking the timecode cable,
in this case, it's this one.
Where is it?
There, timecode in.
You would plug this into this port
and it would synchronize your camera's clock
to the house clock in your machine room.
Once that process takes place,
you can unplug timecode and plug in genlock
and it will then genlock the camera
to your genlock generator in your machine room.
So the only time that you need
to continue jamming timecode
is probably a couple times a day
because there is the possibility
for your camera's clock to drift over time.
And a simple jamming will take care of that.
So I would recommend that you jam timecode
when you first come in during the day,
probably over lunch and then later in the afternoon.
I mentioned genlock.
Well, what is genlock?
Genlock is another type of syncing signal
that helps with making sure that everything
is drawing your pixels and scan line information
at the same time.
So genlock, your machine room will likely have
a genlock generator rack-mounted in your systems there.
That genlock will then be transmitted via wires
to all of your various devices
within your ICVFX facility.
It will go to your control machines,
your render machines, your cameras, your field recorders,
anything that relies on making sure things are synchronized.
So in your render machines in particular,
this is extremely essential
because when you have an LED volume,
especially a large LED volume,
that volume is probably being divided up
amongst a number of different nodes
that are handling specific portions of the screen.
Those nodes, which are handled by end display,
are all being rendered on different computers.
And each computer needs to make sure
that they are rendering the graphics together
at the same time.
If you don't have that happen,
as you see in this particular example
of the bouncing ball here on the screen,
you see how it tears like that on the screen?
That means that the two nodes
that are rendering that information are not in sync.
So in order to put them in sync,
there's an extra card
that you're gonna have to have installed
in each one of these render machines.
It's the Quadro Sync 2 card.
And this card basically resides in a slot.
It actually doesn't have to use that slot
for anything to communicate with the computer.
It just resides in that slot.
You have to hook it up
to your power supply inside of the computer.
And then using the BNC connector
on the backside of the card,
you hook up time code there,
and there will be one machine that will act as a master.
And then that genlock signal can then be passed through
to other render nodes in your machine room
via an internet cable.
And you can see that there are internet connection ports
on the back of that.
This Quadro Sync 2 card basically hooks up
to your your Quadro A6000.
There's ports on top of this card.
You can see that there are four,
actually five ports upon the top.
I think four of them are active
to be able to hook into up to four graphics cards
inside of a single computer.
So you'll basically want to wire connect them
to a connection port on top of the A6000 cards,
along with each A6000 cards
being linked together via SDI, or excuse me, SLI.
Okay, so genlock basically keeps everything
drawing together and in sync.
For tracking systems inside of your facility,
there are a number of different ways
to go about doing this.
There is the OptiTrack system that we have at Latte
and also at the LA R&D stage.
It's running the Motive software,
but you can also use Vicon and Shogun,
also a great alternative.
And for more independent style productions,
and you don't have a very large budget,
you could possibly use the Vive trackers.
And they also have now the Vive Mars system,
which is a very good low cost alternative
for tracking your camera and devices.
All right, in this next section,
we're gonna review the components of the camera
and assemble a camera.
We have a number of particular parts
that you should be taking a look at.
Let's first, we'll go over the table here,
what we've got on the table.
So we've got the Blackmagic Ursa Mini G2.
This is the camera's body.
On top of it, we do have what's called a cheese plate.
This cheese plate can hold various accessories,
a lot of number of different places
where you can screw things into.
In this case, we've got a little arm here
which you can hold our Atomos monitor,
and a place, a connection point
where we'll put on our tracking line.
Over here, this is the camera cage that we have.
It's not a complete full encompassing cage,
but this particular setup here is,
it has a number of additional rails
where we can mount something on the back here
for like a shoulder support,
so it can rest on one's shoulders.
We also have front forward grips
so that when you bring this, you can take this up.
Basically, it mounts like this and so forth.
Usually, it's pretty comfortable.
These are, like I said, these are parts and components
that you can buy at various stores and camera shops
in order to assemble something like this
that you might need.
We have a battery pack, again, gold plate.
Instead of V plate, gold plate, as you can see, gold.
We have a lens.
This is the Zeiss Compact Prime, 25 millimeter lens.
You have the extended data port up on the top,
and you can see that it's a prime.
It's rated at a 25 millimeter.
We've got the tracking mine.
This is the active tracking mine.
This is basically active markers here
along with an inertial measurement unit inside.
You've got the USB and cable connection
that hooks into and powers this particular mine.
The USB port plug-in will plug into the USB port
on the actual camera itself, or excuse me,
the battery itself.
There it is right there, USB connection here.
All right, just for an example,
we do have a passive tracking marker set up here.
This is what we utilized before we got our active tracker.
It's just simply IR reflective little balls here
that are on top of these mounted positions.
This was a 3D printed little connection point,
but in a pinch, this works just in case
we ever have a problem with our active mine.
We also have the Atomos field recorder.
This one's a Shogun model.
This particular field recorder is nice in the fact
that it has a number of connections
on the back for SDI inputs.
It also is really nice in that it comes equipped
with a hard drive.
So this is a four terabyte SSD that simply plugs in.
Soon as we get this on here,
I say simply, there we go,
and slides in and it's connected.
And now you can record anything that the camera sees.
It also has two connections for batteries
that you can plug in here
so that can be battery powered.
It has HDMI in and out as well.
And our connection port point here on the top,
which connects to this connection port here
on your cheese plate.
We do have an extra SDI cable
to hook up the camera to the Atomos
and that's the power supply for the Atomos.
We also have a tripod.
We'll just go over here, just look at this really quick.
You have your tripod,
you have the power supply for the camera,
which is, this is your AC power connector port there.
We also have,
we've hooked up a power strip at the bottom here
to make sure that we are doing our best
to make sure that power is grounded
and that power is protected.
And then we have our series of cables here.
We have SDI out.
We have, if it can be red, Genlock here.
And then we have timecode in
and each one of these are gonna be hooking up
to the ports on the camera.
All right.
So first and foremost,
we need to put our camera onto our mount here.
You can see that there's been a plate
that's been attached to the bottom of the camera
and screwed in.
This plate will effectively mount inside here.
And then on the back,
there's a little connection
that will hold the camera in place.
So we're just gonna basically put this on here.
And of course, it's not gonna be
the easiest thing at times.
Make sure to screw this portion back here in.
The main concern is,
is that you wanna make sure
that the camera is fully locked down,
which as you can see, it's not quite yet.
Of course, it happens all the time.
Don't give up if it does happen this way.
There we go.
It can be fickle.
Tightening it down can be a challenge.
There we go.
The main concern is, is you want it tight.
You don't want the camera to fall off,
obviously for all particular reasons.
All right, we're good.
So the camera is now on its rail system.
We need to mount this onto the tripod.
Now, as you notice here underneath
that there is a specific mounting bracket here,
which slides into on the top of the tripod
on the fluid head.
There is this particular button
that will help to release the camera
when it's being slid onto.
So we're gonna basically mount this here.
It can be challenging.
You see how it slides forward like that?
You might alert you for a moment,
but it won't slide off.
It will go out to this specific point.
And now with this detent button here,
if I slide it back, it will never fall off back.
So that's what's really nice
about these types of systems.
And you can center the camera on it
and lock it into place.
Here we go.
It's all locked in place.
Next, I'll go ahead and take our lens.
We can make sure that with the compact primes,
you've got the extended data port.
You're gonna want to have this facing top side up.
And it's just simply gonna go in
and you're gonna rotate this.
Sorry, there we go.
As such, it's a little bit tricky at times.
You wanna make sure that it gets fully tight
and that the lens is on good.
And then if you want, you can leave the lens cap on
or take it off whenever you're ready.
Okay, let's go ahead and take the Atomos monitor.
And we'll just simply bring it over here
and we will slide it into place.
These are designed to just simply slide and lock.
Once they're on, it won't move anywhere.
And you can position and change this arm here
and have it where you want the most,
depending upon what you need.
I'm gonna just hold it up for a second
cause we'll put the battery on.
The battery, like I said, being gold plate connection,
you've got your mounting points here, here and here.
You're gonna want to align those up as such.
So you slide them on and slide to the right.
Now this battery is connected and can power the camera.
And then at this point, I can kind of re-associate this
so that this is in place.
All right, we'll also go ahead and hook up the mine
just so that we have it on.
Mine is in place.
We have our power connector is over here.
We'll get to hooking up power in just a moment.
Now, before we hook up any kind of SDI cables,
we got to always remember that our accessories
and our camera, everything else needs to be hooked up
with their power first
so that they can be grounded properly.
So on the Atomos, I'll plug in its power supply.
Make sure it's in the grounded strip here.
Our camera also, we want to make sure
its AC power is hooked up.
All right, so now we have camera,
camera power is applied, the Atomos power is applied.
These are two are grounded source,
so that makes me much more comfortable.
Next, we can take the SDI output from the camera
and we can hook it into the Atomos here on the back.
So in this particular case,
I'm going to put it into the 12G in, there we go.
And this should be about ready to go for this.
We need to supply power to the mine.
So if you want to move Sean over to this side,
we need to plug this in here as such.
And then the USB power has to be plugged into the battery
and that is actually over on the other side.
Sorry, Sean.
We have a USB power down here, there we go.
All right, at this particular stage,
now that we have the camera grounded and hooked into power,
we can go ahead and connect our SDI cables.
So we have SDI out, which is going to be
from the SDI port on the camera here.
And then we have a time code in and gen lock in.
So if this is the first time
you are hooking up your camera,
put the time code in first
so that we can jam the time code to the camera.
So we'll go ahead and put time code in, there we go.
All right, so this camera is assembled.
So what we'll do is we'll turn everything on.
We'll turn on the Shogun first.
You'll get a small red dot over here
and the Shogun should power up.
It'll be sitting there waiting.
And then on the Black Magic,
you'll have to come over again over to this side.
Sorry, Sean.
You do have an on-off switch here, which you can turn on.
And we should see here in just a few seconds.
There we go, we're now getting a signal.
And you can see that the time code
has been jammed to the proper time code.
You'll see it here on this side display,
or you can see it here on the Atomos up here at the top.
This one's an hour off
because of daylight savings times.
Once the time code's been jammed,
it's okay then to basically disconnect.
We'll just do it over here.
You can then disconnect the time code cable
and you can now put in the genlock cable.
Before I press that in, just take a look over here.
You'll notice on here,
you see where there's time code across here?
It's missing a specific icon,
which we'll show you when I genlock the camera.
So I'm gonna put in the cable for genlock.
It'll take a few seconds
and you're gonna see things flash for a second.
At least it did on the Atomos monitor,
not on this internal monitor,
but you can see that now there's a small little icon
there that's in a white box.
It says R-E-F or ref.
That means it's now receiving a reference signal
from the genlock of the house genlock generator.
And that completes the assembly of the camera.